I was just joking with Andrew I was like
you know after 3 days of eating in
England I Now understand why Gordon
Ramsay is so [__] mad all the time
the [__] are you
doing dude how bad were those [__]
rice balls oh my God they were soggy
that [__] Mama Celeste Pizza dude
this was funny we walk into this Italian
restaurant and I had this woman Mumble
it was good I was go I go is it good
she's like
unbelievable then I was like oh [__] I
thought they were tourist I don't
understand how you can live this close
to France and Italy and [__] up a
[__] pizza and steak as much as they
do but I'll tell you you know what it is
cuz this is what they they focus all
their [__] on the pubs their pubs are
unbelievable their sports are
unbelievable sense of humor is
unbelievable but the [__] food